it had never been done before nobody had
ever done this before and we got it done
we're all stuck in this call at hotel
california
we went in we never came out during the
entire season that we shot
[Music]
[Music]
it ain't bragging if it's true and i
make the best crepes in the world
egg flour a little milk tiny bit of oil
and then you need this burner the
special swiss burner but anyways that's
not
really why i'm here today i want to
introduce a brand new segment
a brand new episode of ask mr wonderful
and it's absolutely incredible i have
been getting so many questions about how
we shot
shark tank in the middle of a pandemic
and i'm going to tell you i'm going to
share the secrets with you today because
i carried a camera around the whole time
we were doing it
the whole time and what we did
we took over the venetian sands hotel in
las
vegas we sealed the convention center to
the hotel
everybody was quarantined for 11 days
before they got there including
all the entrepreneurs who pitched we
went in we never came out during the
entire
season that we shot you're going to see
some amazing stuff here and you're going
to watch you make incredible crepes
it had never been done before nobody had
ever done this before
and we got it done enjoy part one
of the behind-the-scenes making of shark
tank
season 12 in the bubble
so before i can go to shark tank i have
to get tested for covet 19
as does everybody else that's what's
special this year we're going to work in
a bubble
so everybody has to go in there healthy
so i've got mel the nurse here
and she's going to test me so we're
going to insert it just to the point of
where you start to feel resistant when
you start to feel resistance just going
to give me like a brunch or like
it's going to stay in there for about 10
to 15 seconds around
and then do it again
[Music]
oh man
one of my biggest challenges to moving
to las vegas to shoot shark tank
is moving this entire television studio
there it's a portable studio
but there's a lot of equipment here and
it's all got to go because i got to keep
shooting
i've got a lot of support i have to do
with my companies we shoot commercials
there's lots
lots of social media so you know this is
a
multi-rig set up here everything gets
packed into cases
obviously it's going to take a fair
amount of work
but everything must go as they say
[Music]
social baby you gotta go social
um i have jason calling as well can we
do five yeah
there's this you stand here kevin thank
you
stand there this is what it's gonna be
like
you're gonna tell everybody standing
there oh my god kevin you lost all your
hair during copenhagen
really i think i like bozo the clown
these days i need a haircut so badly
[Music]
so everyone has to go to hair first with
your mask on
i can't put someone like you remember i
would just put someone in an empty chair
whatever was available everyone's got to
go through masks through hair first with
a mask on
then you go into the makeup you stay in
the same chair they come to you
right there's five chairs in there for
each of you all four because lori's in
her room
then they'll come to you and do your
makeup with your mask off when you're
done with your makeup
no more mask you have to grab a visor
you have a choice of two visors one's
handheld
so you don't screw up your makeup by
putting a mask on
we'll show it to you you have either a
handheld mask like a plexi
or there's one that has like sort of a
collar it looks like a dog collar
and it goes up like this this is one
choice you have two options
where you can walk around that's very
attractive after you're done with makeup
and the other option i'll try and find
it while we're walking around
but it doesn't you don't have to hold it
it goes around your neck
i think i want the dog collar yeah so i
want to use my hands to text yeah there
you go
right on again so these you will need
when you leave here to go to your
dressing room and when you go to your
dressing room to the stage
and then and you will walk on and sit in
your chair with them and then we will
take them away from you
thank you and when you exit your chair
we will give them back to you and you
will take it and you will go off the
stage oh there's going to be some great
social things
shark path oh i got to get a picture of
that
we'd prefer to have our truck days go
get you what you need and have you guys
run back and forth
the craft service is nothing like we've
had before
so here you each have your own chair and
your
area this is before we start
before we put you on the set we'll bring
you here for last look at the touch-ups
as soon as it pitches come back out here
as we turn around over here so what will
happen is as soon as it pitches over
we're going to send the shark
pas in and maybe me and we're going to
give you your visors and you're going to
walk off
and you have to be here with it it's
going to be standing by and sanitized
for you
over here during the pitches and we'll
bring it in for you got it at the end of
the pitches
okay wow what a setup yeah
my
it's pretty it's gonna be roughly to say
you see we got a little shark pond for
you guys over there
the shark fine so after the pitches you
guys get up you go over there
we do our sanitation between the pitch
between every pitch
[Music]
yes
yeah thank you so much you're so welcome
to the line baby for the line where's my
line yeah that line right there that's
it
all right got a space shield on yeah you
know the gopro
i got everything everything that's the
ap
perpetual with a red band i like that
that's my watch for the uh the day
cool yeah all right are you ready to
roll
oh yeah for sure that looks like a nice
uh
fake rolex theron you know it's funny i
bought it on the streetcar
it looks like the real thing
don't come into my space don't worry i'm
not coming near it
it's teeming with death robber
chocolate thunder she said it was
awesome
thank you for coming you're welcome
come on in kevin
who is the guy that comes over for
dinner and you haven't invited his
friends and he comes with 17 people
and doesn't announce it who's the guy
that comes over for dinner with a giant
3 000 bottle of wine and shows it to you
and
tells you how much it's worth and then
insist on taking it home
who's the first guest you never want to
invite for business
why or anything why do they call me mr
wonderful
because there's truth in advertising
[Music]
uh-huh
i think these are more than double what
they're listed yeah correct they're hard
to get but i want to tell you about this
particular piece michael why i made it
first
on our discussions when i leave here
today i'm going to fedex this piece
i'll say goodbye to it forever to
phillips auction house it is going to be
featured
in the prince of monaco prince albert's
charity auction in december for water
called one drop
the one drop foundation was founded by
gila liberte who's also the founder of
cirque du soleil
his highness prince albert ii of monaco
is also partnered
with all of us so of course we start
with the first lot
in this section lot 63 your 116500
ln daytona with ceramic bezel
white dial and of course your signature
red band
i have to tell you your watch has
generated tremendous
interest already i'm very happy to hear
that i just want to say something about
this watch
this daytona has been
with me through some incredible times
it's been almost everywhere in the world
i've been
it's been on good morning america cnbc
shark tank cnn bbc
that is a television watch if that watch
could talk
i mean there is no it's that daytona
that one that daytona now maybe i can
replace
it but it won't be that piece
that that piece is that's a that's a i'm
looking at it and i'm almost starting to
cry
that piece is spectacular it is such an
incredible watch
whoever gets it will understand exactly
what i'm talking about
watches in the world for us insecure men
like kevin o'leary
of all your watches this is one of my
favorites why
because it is very sparkly if your ego
is not intact
and you want to act like a big shot you
want this watch it's the best in the
business for small he goes
so full of crap when you look at the
dial here like all the it's
just very sparkly it's like a jewel well
it's an absolute classic it's elegant
very versatile it goes with everything
and you know it just
it's for a certain distinguished kind of
gentleman and i absolutely love the way
that mr wonderful here does it with his
own flair with the pop of red
i mean it just stands out so much
just beautiful just beautiful
perfect
[Laughter]
i just love it you know i love making
crepes
make them now serve them all week long
people absolutely love them
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe